fox news medical correspondent dr mark
siegel
uh mark let me just put to you um
following on from what i've just said
open where possible
closed where necessary i think the
central question that a lot of people
have been putting to me and you hear it
all the time
which is why can't we just protect the
vulnerable and everyone else can go on
with their lives that was being rejected
by some i want to read you this quote
and ask you to respond this is an
article in the atlantic a lot of people
were looking at which is how does the
coronavirus end
the quote is this high-risk people such
as the elderly
could be protected while lower-risk
people are allowed to go back to work
such thinking is seductive but flawed it
overestimates our ability to assess a
person's risk
and to somehow wall off the high-risk
people from the rest of the society
why is that flawed why can't we do a
more targeted strategy
steve i think we can do a more targeted
strategy i think that that argument is
flawed but there is a missing piece that
i want to bring up to you
it's called rapid point of care testing
we now have it uh abbott put out a test
they claim they can test 50
000 people a day it's in a small box
you go to it they do a tiny nasal swab
not the big cumbersome thing we've been
talking about five to 13 minutes later
they tell you whether you have covet 19
or not
that's the first answer to this question
if i know that people
don't have it i feel much more secure
about them going to work
obviously if i know they do have it
maybe i can use
universities that are now shut or hotels
or have them shelter in place at home if
they can do that safely
i can select them out from the community
at large
and let people who don't have covet 19
go back to work
the the floored argument is basically
saying if we don't know who has it
then we have to consider young people or
healthy people as typhoid mary's they
might end up with it
and spread it to a higher risk group but
that it's time now
for that thinking in the blind to go
away we can tell who has it now and we
need to test wider groups of people
and do you think that can be ramped up
sufficiently in the next month we've got
this extra month now with the extension
of the
uh guidelines this was announced today
do you think that gives us enough time
to get to that point with the testing
i think it better and i think we're
going to put emphasis on that tonight
and i think it will and i think we have
the ability to
i want to say two other things about
that steve first i want to echo your
point about suicide because
unemployment and pandemics are both high
risk of suicide high risk of
depression it's what we call collateral
damage in medicine
and it's so important that you are
focusing on that tonight and that
people with a very narrow vision ignore
that but that's the overall damage done
second point i want to make is
in addition to the test i talked about
we now have a blood test
that henry shine has put out that can
tell us who is immune and who's not
immune
literally somebody walking around with
immunity to this virus or who had it
before and we now know they're over it
in a way they're they're a protective
group that group can certainly get back
to work if you have your
immune cells if you have antibodies to
the virus we know you had it we know
you're over it
you can go back to work so these tests
are crucial
to flying in the face of what the
atlantic is trying to say they're wrong
provided that i have the information i
need i think i can get that information
very rapidly i think we have the
technology and it's time our health care
system works the way it's supposed to
the pot the private public partnership
here finally the fda has approved these
two tests it took too long
now is the time to get it widely
circulated both of these tests one a
blood test
and one a nasal swab
so just to just to sort of wrap it up
there um
open where possible closed where
necessary sounds like you support that
strategy but it only works if you have
widespread testing not just of those
people with symptoms
but of everyone is that am i
understanding you correctly
i want to qualify that and say two
things everyone who may have it or may
have been in contact
with someone who had it that's the group
i want tested could you have it
do you have that cough shortness of
breath do you have symptoms i'm
concerned about
and who you are in contact with and the
second point i want to make and this is
i think you
probably agree with me we need to worry
about the epicenters right
so if i can test around the epicenters
the areas the hot zones we're calling
them
well maybe in the middle of montana
you're okay and can go back to work
maybe in the you know the rural areas
areas where this virus isn't hitting
19 states have not seen major cases here
those places should certainly be
reopened if we can be sure
that they don't have a lot of virus
absolutely
great well thank you for your expertise
on on this tonight and
every day and every night we really
appreciate it dr siegel thanks so much
and see you soon